hello everyone and welcome to this first
session of our metagenomics training
program so what we'll do today is i'll
talk briefly about some of the basic
things that you have to know about
metagenomics for some of you this will
be a review for some of you many things
might be new but i'll also point you to
some resources on our portal
where you can find important information
uh either on the basic
terms that we will use throughout the
program
as well as some practical exercises that
you can get started with
so like i said i will talk a little bit
about some of the terminology some of
the methods that are used to generate
the data
and i'll also talk a little bit about
the types of projects that we will
review or case studies where you can
really see how metagenomics is used now
together with myself dr raghavendran
lakshmi narayan is going to be mentoring
the program and in the next session he
will talk to you more about the
technical details
but also this is a program that
is designed for you to succeed and so
we're hoping that you will update your
profile let us know about your
background your research interests or
your industry interest and really
allow us to connect with you our team
will reach out to you if you have any
questions and we have a support group on
skype or on slack where we can interact
and address any questions that you might
have
so the purpose of today's session is to
discuss
the microbiome how we can use
metagenomic sequence analysis to study
the microbiome
and understand how microorganisms
interact in their natural environment
looking at the community composition and
structure
thinking about species richness and
understanding the functional roles that
some of these microbial communities can
play in many areas related to human
health and disease as well as
biotechnology and agriculture
so the program is really designed to
introduce
different types of case studies that
illustrate the way the field of
metagenomics has been evolving what are
some of the practical tools and skills
that you have to have to be able to
analyze this data independently and also
what are some practical tips tutorials
and maybe skills that you should have to
be able to
integrate this
quantity of information from different
databases from the reads in the fastq
files and also the different metadata
that you have about your samples to
produce
plots that help you interpret the data
biologically so you'll be able to by the
end of this program process a data set
understand the composition ask questions
about the microbiome and review
literature that will help you find
answers and make biological sense of the
data that you have analyzed
the way the program is organized is it's
really divided up into several different
stage
stages
the first one is logic
then we will talk about practice and
then we will
kind of transition into a project stage
so why is logic important
logic is important because we need to
understand
what kind of data are we going to be
dealing with
and what kinds of questions could
potentially be asked of this data
now different types of data represent
different types of biological
phenomena and so we
can generate data that describe this
biological phenomenon
but depending on what kind of data we
have about maybe
the phenomena maybe the number of
samples
or the way that we
plan to process and analyze the data
will determine what kinds of questions
we can ask
so moving a little bit more into the
practical domain we will talk about
different types of analytical approaches
now the analytical approaches can be
divided into two types
the first one is processing or really
preparing the data for analysis
and then the second one is more on how
to work with the process data and make
sense of it and that can include
several different things so one of them
is kind of a standard process which we
call a pipeline where we take the input
files we go through several different
steps and we get some predefined output
in many cases
that kind of an output requires further
investigation and that is driven both by
statistical analysis visualization
machine learning and sometimes it's
driven by a biological intuition
and so that's where we cannot cover
everything that potentially could be
done but this will be more based on a
case study so in each case we will see
what kinds of questions are being asked
what methods are being used to process
the data how is that data then analyzed
visualized and annotated and then what
kinds of interpretation or conclusions
we can arrive
helping to study and find relationships
between phenotype and what we find in
this microbiome or metagenomic data
so this will be covered in several
different sessions
some of the sessions will be live like
today
some of them will be pre-recorded
today's session is live you can ask us
questions you can comment if you have
any specific things that you expect from
this program we would love to know but
in many cases we want to give you the
flexibility of going through the topics
that we have planned and so that is why
all of the sessions will be recorded but
also sometimes you will have access to a
structured material
on our omixlogic portal which will
include
text images video quizzes exercises with
coding or running pipelines
and that's why it's important to get
familiar already
with the portal how it works and how the
different contents present on that
portal can be leveraged and there you
will find
some basic coursework
as well as practical exercises in r and
python
we'll primarily talk about r
because it's extensively used in
metagenomic data analysis and also
because it is providing us with very
nice looking figures that we can
directly use in research publications
but the online portal really covers the
basics uh some practical and
gives you some case studies that are
structured around publications where
experts have been analyzing the data and
coming to those conclusions so it's a
good way to understand not only how to
technically approach a subject but how
have experts designed
sequence the data and made the
interpretation of the results
together with the portal we will be
using the t-violin for platform
so the tbi info platform is a
point-and-click interface that allows
you to analyze big data without having
to download the data to your computer
without having to learn how to write
code in bash
and really connect multiple complex
analysis methods into a process a
pipeline where you can get results that
are interpretable in a quicker way
so to demonstrate how this is used in
the context of metagenomics i will show
you a brief example and then we will
talk about how
that can be used
either to study metagenomics or to
understand the relationship between
phenotype and the specific types of data
that we will be working with
so let me transition from my slides to
the actual portal now if you have
already signed up on the onyx logic
portal and you have access now to
uh the program
your account information should be uh
also
should allow you to log in to this
portal to this platform called the
tbionfor platform
so i'll pause here thank you jesse for
sharing the link
please let me know
those that are participating and want to
follow along if you were able to
get into this link and also if you hover
over this profile if you can see your
email address here on top so you know
that you're logged in
and maybe you can share that in the chat
yes no
uh
maybe something like that so i will give
you just a couple of minutes and then we
will go on from there
okay if you still have not created an
account
then i recommend going first to the
learn portal
and on the learn portal
you can easily create a free account
unfortunately if you're just creating
your account today you won't have access
to the portal to the platform right away
it will take a little bit of time for
you to receive those credentials so if
you don't have the credentials you can
just observe but for the next session i
highly recommend to try and log in and
if you're not able to log in or you have
some issues with logging in please
support our or please reach out to our
support team
at
support at pine.com
all right so
let's move on
and here you will see a
section a table called areas of analysis
you will see here many different types
of analysis included transcriptomic data
genomic data epigenomic data et cetera
and right here at the bottom we have a
dedicated section for metagenomic data
analysis
so metagenomic data
comes in several different formats and
that's why we have them divided into
several different sections
we'll talk about some of them and we'll
use some of them quite extensively to
analyze data you will find that
the selection of methods
is driven in many cases by the type of
data that you have and so we'll talk a
little bit about the types of
metagenomic data in just a few minutes
but today i will show you a brief
example of a specific type of data
called amplicon
16s ribosomal rna gene
where we amplify the 16s ribosomal rna
gene to understand the composition of a
sample
and so this
link right here will give us access to a
demo
in the demo we can build a pipeline
without having to upload data and right
away get results so we don't have to
wait for the processing time either
so if you do have access you can click
on there and you can follow along with
me if you don't you can just observe and
again you will have an exercise for next
time where you can follow along
now every time that you click on a
button you get a description that
explains what are we going to do and how
and so in this case we're going to be
using the data 2 pipeline data 2
pipeline was developed specifically
because this kind of data
is noisy it has a lot of issues a lot of
issues that
can make finding signal difficult
and so because it is made to denoise the
data
we have to go through a whole series of
steps to first clean up the reads and
prepare them for the downstream analysis
and so that's what we're going to do
first we're going to check our quality
of the reads
then we're going to select only reads
that are paired
after that we're going to merge those
pairs together
then we will assign
operational taxonomic units to
those merged pairs of reads and remove
chimera creates rates that came from
several different locations so they kind
of create this hybrid that cannot be
annotated
once we do this we have to use a
database a reference that helps us
assign each one of those sequences
to a taxonomic level
and the taxonomic level basically has a
database of sequences and the closest
sequence helps us align
the otus with the taxonomy
after we have that information we want
to understand what types of sequences do
we have and to do that we have to create
a phylogenetic tree the phylogenetic
tree in this case
can be created using this a package in r
which stands for analysis of
phylogenetics and evolution
once we have that phylogenetic tree we
can then start inter
kind of analyzing and integrating all of
that information
to perform statistical analysis and
study the composition of our sample and
that can be done with a package called
filoseek again we will go through these
packages during our sessions and we we
can use them in r or we can use them on
the platform but what they do is they
integrate the statistical analysis with
plotting and we will see how this
plotting helps us understand
what kind of data we have
and to the question in the chat yes this
video is going to be available
for everyone to see
but especially important for those that
are participating in the full program
and then we're just going to produce
some visual interactive visualization on
the platform that will allow us to study
the data set that we
have okay so for those of you
that followed along your pipeline
connects all of these dots together and
what you have in the end are output
files that you can download
and they typically are produced
from every step that we selected there
will be something
from those steps but also we have here
several plots that we can view
interactively
so
the first important plot is the
tax-a-proportionate abundance bar plot
and again you will have a whole session
dedicated to
how this plot is produced and and what
exactly does it represent but here
briefly i would like to point your
attention to several important things
first of all
when we talk about metagenomic data that
represents the microbiome we're studying
a whole community together and because
we have different levels
of
depth for the different samples that we
have samples here are on the x-axis we
are expecting a lot of variation and so
we want to
perform normalization by looking at
proportionate abundance and not direct
abundance from these samples
so once we have them we can now see that
specific taxa
again here we have the full taxonomic
classification written out but as you
remember bacteria is the kingdom right
so it's not going to change but then
after this you see that some of these
taxonomic levels are going to start to
change and so as we look at our
proportions here we can see this green
taxa which is bacterial dts
vary between our samples
and so the obvious question now
is okay what does that tell us about the
samples themselves right this is a lot
of detail how do we
kind of look at this detail from a high
level to understand what kinds of
differences do we have and to do that
and we're going to again go through this
in detail in one of our sessions we use
a statistical analysis called non-metric
denim
dimensionality scaling
which is a plot in 3d
that we can look at and we can see here
each one of these dots represents a
sample that we just saw
so here we have the samples on the
x-axis and on the y-axis proportional
abundance here in our nmds plot we have
three dimensions
that are from the non-metric
dimensionality scaling and the dots
represent in the individual sample so
you can see that the samples are of two
types
chao which is a standard type of feed
used for mice and hfd which stands for
high fat diet
and so as we look around we can notice
two major things
the first one is that we have an
outlier and the second one is that
actually if we probably removed the
outlier
we would be able to see some
pretty good separation between our
samples right if we find some kind of a
way to position this plot we could find
a line that could separate the dots so
of course that is dependent on removing
this outlier and that is really the
essence of this type of analysis that we
will go through in the full program
this analysis is going to be iterative
which means that you will start
somewhere
you will perform some standard tasks and
then you will start asking questions
what do i see and what does it mean and
if i understand what it means what are
some next steps that i should take to
make sure that i'm getting something
that i understand
makes sense but also is reproducible and
could tell me something about the
biology that i'm trying to study
so this is a very brief example again we
will go into much more detail throughout
the program but it illustrates the
essence of the type of bioinformatics
steps that you would have to go through
and understand to be able to work with
such microbiome data